oh it's grace oh hello grace helbig here
from the YouTube channel it's grace and
you're watching NMR it stands for new
media rockstars that you know where you
are you're on the website already the
transition into its grace has been
amazing it's been a real testament to
the fact that YouTube is based on
community because a lot of my friends a
lot of the guests that we've had on this
show have voluntarily promoted the
channel and driven traffic and really
supported the whole transition and you
never really know what's gonna happen
when you start something new and you
leave something behind I feel really
good about it the show that we're
shooting in the YouTube space is called
not too deep with grace Helbig and it is
this hybrid podcast partial video
partial audio I did Rhett and Link's air
biscuit podcast and they are great human
beings and they make you feel so
comfortable when you're around them that
you leave the podcast thinking that you
just had a therapy session and I thought
oh what's the opposite of this
I think it was called the history of the
world by using missiles it's the only
part that I remember a walrus playing
saxophone the trainer next to him kids
in saxophone he starts playing it like
this and the best part is the trainer
and the background just starts dancing
like this he's so into it I don't
remember the actual first channel that I
subscribed to but one of the first
channels was lisanova
and natalie tran communitychannel and
they were two huge inspirations and me
creating my own channel
sometimes I like to unsubscribe and
re-subscribe to my brother's channel own
Tim will destroy you just to see if he
notices so that I would say my brother
take that to him
I met Cleopatra would have like an
amazing beauty guru thing going on those
winged eyeliner better than any manures
I seen on YouTube right now it's gonna
sound more because he died kernel meow
the cat that is famous I did not like
that cat at all and I feel so bad saying
it now because of the death thing but if
he's in a better place next question
well some of the world has heard of will
- its Miranda sings and Flula Borg
that's their amazingly hilarious and if
you don't think so I don't want to be
around you
the Tyler Oakley glozell shaycarl maybe
that little girl that sings with her dad
no the walrus but the walrus up there